[Music]
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec I reached out to these
innovative Finnish entrepreneurs of all
things because a very skilled Acrobat
introduced me to one of their products
which is a mushroom coffee made out of
chaga mushroom powerful antioxidant
considered a superfood I was introduced
to chaga by Laird Hamilton of all people
and another mushroom called lion's mane
which is considered a no tropic or a
smart drug and I had half a packet let
me put this in perspective tasted just
like coffee just add to hot water only
20 milligrams in half a packet of
caffeine that's as little as 1/10 what
you would find in a strong cup of coffee
and I was on fire for the entire day I
probably got more done in that day than
I got done in the 3 or 4 days prior to
that so I would highly recommend
checking it out it is very impressive
you will not see visuals so you can use
it for work and you can check it out at
4 sigma tech comm forward slash Tim
that's for sig Matic SI GM ATI c-calm
forward slash Tim and use the code Tim
to get 20% off your first order I highly
encourage you to try it out
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss Show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
hello my later Mogwai this is tim
ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show where it is
typically my responsibility to distill
expertise or I should say rather habits
tactics tools that are from world-class
performers those things that you can
test in your own life apply to your own
life whether they are from the world of
say entertainment sports military or in
this case chess Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
Tai Chi push hints but this episode is
going to be an experimental episode I
want to try a few things that are
adapted from share a few things that are
adapted from my new book tools of
Titan's you can find it on Barnes and
noble.com amazon.com the everybody they
should be available and it's also a
highlight reel in effect that you guys
many of you thousands of you have asked
me for and we're gonna invite back one
of my favorite people on the planet Josh
Waitzkin endlessly fascinating guy Josh
Waitzkin you can find him at Josh
Waitzkin calm was the basis for the book
and the movie searching for bobby
fisher' he was considered a chess
prodigy but he is perfected learning
strategies that can be applied to
anything by anyone and I really mean
that including his loves of Brazilian
jiu-jitsu he's a black belt under I
think he was the first black belt under
phenom marcelo garcia we'll talk more
about him and Taichi push hints in which
he was a world champion these days he
spends his time very quietly coaching
the world's top athletes and investors
working to revolutionize education we
we've partnered on a number of things
there and tackling his new passion of
paddle surfing and in the latter very
often nearly killing me in the process I
first met Josh after reading his book
the art of learning and as I think I've
mentioned we've become very dear friends
empty space josh has no social media
does no interviews
except for my podcast for which he very
often says to me or text me you [ __ ]
after all he is from New York City and
avoids nearly all meetings and phone
calls he is perhaps the best I've met
actually there's one other Rick Rubin
who's been on the podcast as well
legendary music producer he minimizes
input to maximize output and as Josh
would say quote I cultivate empty space
as a way of life for the creative
process end quote so you might ask
yourself how are you creating empty
space how are you creating the slack
necessary to connect dots that perhaps
you haven't connected before come up
with original ideas josh is an expert
here I cultivate empty space as a way of
life for the creative process worming
the macro from the micro Josh really
focuses on depth over breadth in
everything he often uses a principle
nicknamed learning the macro from the
micro this means focusing on something
very small in a field whether that's in
chess martial arts or elsewhere to
internalize extremely powerful macro
principles that apply everywhere and
I'll give you a few examples this is
also sometimes combined with beginning
with the endgame and I will illustrate
that for instance when Josh gave me a
beginner's tutorial on chess he didn't
start with opening moves memorizing
openings is natural of course and nearly
everyone does it but Josh likens it to
stealing the test answers from a teacher
you're not learning principles or
strategies you're merely learning a few
tricks that will help you beat your
novice friends instead Josh took me in
the complete reverse just as his first
teacher bruce pandolfini did with him so
he took off all of the pieces empty
bored and he added three back in an
endgame scenario where he would usually
finish the game King and pawn against
king so in this case through the micro
positions of vastly reduced complexity
he was able to force me to focus on the
macro principles like the power of empty
space opposition
or setting an opponent up for zoogs Wong
which is a situation where any move he
makes will destroy his position so by
limiting me to a few simple pieces he
hoped that I would learn something
limitless high-level concepts that I
could apply anytime against anyone I've
seen Josh do this himself too many
things including for instance jiu-jitsu
where he can cover nearly all of the
principles of jiu-jitsu the main tenets
that will help you compete at a high
level by focusing on a single submission
again the endgame called in this case
the guillotine are specifically the
Marcelo teen from marcelo garcia and
after he gave me this tutorial in chess
which was actually part of it was
recorded there's an extended scene
that's available in the TV show i did
called the tim ferriss experiment I went
to Washington Square Park and lasted
about 10 times longer than I ever have
before competing against these street
hustlers and that was literally from
practicing no openers no nothing aside
from these high level principles with
three pieces on the board
pretty cool stuff if you're studying my
game you're entering my game Josh and I
spend a lot of time discussing and in
some cases hanging out with her training
with marcelo garcia five-time world
champion in brazilian jiu-jitsu with
whom josh owns the marcelo garcia
academy in new york city which i highly
recommend if you have a chance they have
a very strict no [ __ ] no bully policy
and it's probably also the cleanest and
certainly one of the most competitive
jiu-jitsu gyms in the world
so marcelo who is marcelo Marcelo's
arguably the best grappler of the last
hundred years he's considered the
combined mike tyson Wayne Gretzky and
Michael Jordan of his sport and whereas
most competitors are very secretive
about their their training for
competition their competition prep
Marcelo does the opposite he routinely
records and uploads his exact sparring
sessions in other words his exact
training for major events which all his
competitors can watch Josh explains the
rationale when he was competing it out
with Bobby's submission grappling world
championship and when jaws which is the
Brazilian jiu-jitsu world championship
we were spirt we were streaming his
sparring sessions every night
so he was basically showing his
competitors what he was about to use
against them except for ease and his
attitude about this which is completely
unique is if you're studying my game
you're entering my game and I'll be
better at than you I often share exact
under-the-hood details of how for
instance I've built the podcast or put
together Kickstarter campaigns and so on
I do this really for two reasons and
they're reflective of two core beliefs
so let's talk about those belief number
one it's rarely a zero-sum game in other
words if someone wins someone else must
lose that's just not the case it's
rarely a zero-sum came in something like
podcasting and the more that I help
people with details the more detail to
help I receive in turn belief number two
if it is competitive I'm simply offering
people the details of my game right my
attention to detail will scare off half
of the people right off the bat who
would have tried so now we're down to
50% of the people who have heard it or
read it or observed it 40% will try it
and be worse than me because it's my
game right
I'm capitalizing on my strengths with my
particular strategies and so on but 10%
will try it and be better than me now is
this a problem or is it not and I would
just say see belief number one that 10%
will often reach out to me to teach me
exactly what they learned and did to get
better results because they are grateful
for what I offered in the first place
which was transparency so call it karma
call it anything you might like I call
it very very useful and plus it's just a
a more offensive and not defensive way
to live and to perform in a professional
arena for me
remember the last returns I remember
when I went skiing with Billy Kidd who I
recall one of them the great downhill
racers from back in the sixties Olympic
ski team awesome dude now he skis out in
Colorado wearing a cowboy hat just
timeless guy brilliant dude and you know
he was saying to me years ago when I
first skied with him Josh what do you
think of the three most important turns
of the ski run and you know I've asked
that question to a lot of people since
and most people will say the middle
because it's the hardest the beginning
is they're getting momentum Billy
describes the three most important turn
to the ski runner the last three before
he got in the lift and it's a very very
subtle point and for those of you are
skiers you know that you know that's
when the slope is leveled off is less
challenged most people are very sloppy
then they're taking the muscles off of
they're taking the weight off the
muscles they've been using they have bad
form problem with that is it on the lift
right up unconsciously you're
internalizing a bad body mechanics as
Billy points out if you your last
returns are precise than what you're
internalizing lift right up is precision
so I carry this on to you know the guys
who I trained in the finance world for
example ending the workday with very
high quality which opens up for one
thing you're internalizing quality over
night thanks to Josh I now always end
training sessions on a good rep per se
whether that's acro yoga you can
definitely learn more about that by
listening to my episode with Jason Nemer
gymnastics check out coach summer
archery or other for instance even if I
have 60 minutes budgeted for a workout
if I hit a fantastic PR in other words a
personal record at say 45 minutes or do
something new particularly well in
gymnastics I pack it in that's the end
of the workout in the case of archery
which is a new passion of mine I also
use what's called blank Bale practice
and a bale like a hay bale they would
use that you would put a target on and
aim for a blank Bale is where I start
and end all sessions with five to six
arrows shop I feel alone eyes closed
into a target that is a mere ten feet
away so I'm not aiming at anything and
this is similar in many senses to dry
firing with firearms or handguns for
instance to try to minimize any type of
flinching that you might have an
anticipation of the
shot and you're able to then
kinesthetically incorporate the the fine
motor control that will ultimately aid
you in other circumstances one of Josh's
favorite writers Hemingway had a
practice of ending his writing sessions
mid flow and mid sense this way he knew
exactly where to start the next day and
he could reliably both end and start his
sessions with confidence to turn it on
learn to turn it off as vice versa or
some other see every we were talking
about one of my most beautiful memories
of him and you know World Championship
before going into the semi-finals
raucous bleacher everyone's screaming
yelling he's sleeping wake him up he
sort of stumble into the ring you've
never seen a guy more relaxed before
going into a World Championship fight
and then he can turn it off so deeply
and then when he goes in the ring you
can't turn on with any more intent to me
he can and his ability to turn it off is
directly aligned with how intensely you
can turn it on so training people to do
this have stress and recovery undulation
throughout their day the little things
are the big things we're talking about
Marcelo talking about or embodying the
principle of quality in all these little
ways these little ways you could say
don't matter but they add up to to
matter hugely oh I think the little
things are the big things yeah because
they're a reflection I mean this might
sound cliche but it's like how you do
anything is how you do everything right
and it's such a it's such an abuse and
we don't most people think they can wait
around for the big moments to turn it on
but if you don't cultivate turning it on
as a way of life the little moments
there's and there's hundreds of times
more little moments than big and there's
no chance in the big moments
just go around for life I mean lateral
thinking or thematic thinking the
ability to take a lesson from one thing
and transferred over to another I think
is one of the most important disciplines
that any of us can cultivate or ways of
being and it's something that Jack and I
have from a really young age we began to
cultivate this from when he was really
small around this principle of go around
we we would we would initially it was
like the first thing that time it
happened is that he was trying it was
really tiny he was trying to get in
we're in a little cottage a single
cottage in a Inn on Martha's Vineyard
tiny little cottage in a big field and
he was trying to get in one door and he
couldn't but he could get in the other
door and I said Jack go around and he
looked at me and he went around and then
go around became a language for us
physically
if you can't go one way you go around to
another way but then it became a
language for us in terms of solving
puzzles and in terms of anyway tell me
were running an obstacle go around and
then working with the metaphor of go
around opened up this way that we would
just have dialogue around connecting
things right taking a way of a principle
from one thing and applying it something
else and we've had a lot of fun with
that
embrace your funk um that's a term my
buddy
Graham who's who's a dear friend of ours
who's comes on our surf adventures for
this he's a brilliant thought partner
embrace the funk could you explain that
yeah we have to embrace our funk we have
to figure out what you know you think
about the the entanglement of genius and
madness right or brilliance and
eccentricity a understanding that
entanglement is always a precursor to
working with anybody who's trying to be
world-class at something because that
entanglement is fundamental to their
being and they have to ultimately
impress embrace their funk embrace their
eccentricity embrace what makes them
different and then build on it
who do you pick when your ego seems
threatened it's very interesting to
observe who the top competitors pick out
when they're 5 rounds into the sparring
sessions and they're completely guessed
the ones who are in the steepest growth
curve look for the hardest guy they're
the one who beat them up who might beat
him up while others will look for
someone they can take a break on the
importance of language on a rainy day
one of the biggest mistakes that I
observed in the first year of Jack's
life we are two of jack-up that I've
observed with parents is that they do
that have this language around whether
whether being good or bad and whenever
the weather when it was raining they'd
be like it's bad weather here you know
mom's babysitter's dads talk about it's
bad weather we can't go out or it's good
weather we can go out and so that means
that somehow we're externally reliant on
conditions being perfect in order to be
able to go out and have a good time so
Jack and I never missed a single storm
every rainstorm I don't that we I don't
think we've missed one storm other than
maybe one when he was sick but we had on
that we've I don't think we've missed a
single storm rain or snow along that
side and romping in it and we've develop
this language around how beautiful it
was and so when now whenever there's a
rainy day jack says looked at at such a
beautiful rainy day and we go out and we
play in it and you know I wanted him to
have this internal locus of control
right to not be reliant on external
conditions being just so
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that have somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than ten asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest eight thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
com forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of this episode is brought to you
by four sig Matic I reached out to these
innovative Finnish entrepreneurs of all
things because a very skilled Acrobat
introduced me to one of their products
which is a mushroom coffee made out of
chaga mushroom powerful antioxidant
considered a superfood I was introduced
to chaga by Laird Hamilton of all people
and another mushroom called lion's mane
which is considered a no tropic or a
smart drug
and I had half a packet let me put this
in perspective tasted just like coffee
just add the hot water only 20
milligrams in half a packet of Kaffee
and that's it's as little as 1/10 what
you would find in a strong cup of coffee
and I was on fire for the entire day I'd
probably got more done in that day than
I got done in the three or four days
prior to that so I would highly
recommend checking it out it is very
impressive you will not see visuals so
you can use it for work and you can
check it out at four sigma tech comm
forward slash Tim that's four sig Matic
si GM ATI c-calm forward slash Tim and
use the code Tim to get 20% off your
first order I highly encourage you to
try it out
[Applause]